et on va retourner voir notre
épidémiologistes madame catherine hill
la connexion normalement a été récupéré
on est ravi de vous revoir madame il
alors vous nous expliquer un petit peu
vos craintes de ces jeunes qui sont
entassés sur les quais sans masque
puisque vous disiez que pour vous le
plus dangereux c'était les
asymptomatiques qui risquait donc de
contaminer les personnes les plus
fragiles peut-être chez eux alors la
question suivante c'est justement ce
week end de l'ascension pour vous est ce
que c'est ce type de week-end qui est le
week end de tous les dangers il fait
beau les gens sont dehors avec notamment
des parcs fermés à paris est ce que
c'est un danger
ça suffit d inquiétude selon vous mais
les gens se déplacent et ils vont
rencontrer des personnes qui ne
rencontre pas d'habitude surtout qu'ils
n'ont pas rencontré pendant qu'ils ont
été confinés donc si vous rencontrez
plus de gens vous aurez plus de chance
de tomber sur le virus c'est juste
mathématiques c'est bête mais ça marche
et le virus est partout dans le pays on
voit bien alors on a tous ces foyers
quand là qu'on détecte parce que
maintenant quand on trouve un cas
symptomatique
on teste les gens autour et évidemment
quand on tourne d'un cap positif
il ya d'autres cas c'est totalement
obligatoire c'est la caractéristique de
la maladie contagieuse donc plus et j'en
rencontre d'autres gens ses amis qui ne
se sont pas vus depuis longtemps qui se
retrouvent ils augmentent leurs chances
de tomber sur le virus et et la personne
en qui ils ont confiance peut avoir été
contaminées allez on a déjà les chiffres
pour le moment évidemment on reste
prudents sont plutôt rassurants mais
vous allez me dire certainement que ce
ne sont pas les vrais chiffres liés aux
premiers effets
du déconfinement pour cela il va falloir
patienter jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
pour reconnaître les premiers effets
justement oui bien sûr les
hospitalisations arrive peut-être huit
ou dix jours après la contamination
les entrées en réanimation arrive encore
après et les morts encore plus tard donc
on a des indicateurs qui sont très
retardé on est en train de voir les
effets du confinement mais on voit pas
les effets du déconfinement il faudra un
peu de temps pour vous de voir
alors à quel à partir de quel seuil on
pourrait parler de deuxième vague selon
vous quel est le chiffre encore entre
guillemets acceptable pour un médecin
mais c'est très simple en ce moment il
ya encore cinq mille personnes en
réanimation dans le pays ce qui est
énorme
si on ajoute un peu moins de 2000 pour
coville 19 il ya aussi tous les autres
qui sont en réanimation parce qu'on les
a opéré et qu'ils ont besoin d'être en
réanimation pour d'autres raisons
donc on nous a dit qu'il y avait 5000
places en tout et il ya encore cinq
mille personnes en réanimation et en
plus et sont pas répartis également dans
le pays elles sont surtout en ile de
france et probablement aussi dans le
grand est est un peu dans le nord donc
la situation encore extraordinairement
tendue par exemple en ile de france ou
dans de grotesques donc il ya un
problème là et donc des si ça repart un
peu ça va devenir insupportable pour les
services médicaux qui sont très
hospitaliers qui ont déjà été très
saturé pendant des semaines et des
semaines
alors on le voit la france dé confine
pas que d'ailleurs la france dans les
autres pays européens on parle de l'art
ouverture des frontières les magasins
rouvrent également
c'était une mauvaise stratégie selon
vous on va peut-être trop vite ou le
respect des gestes barrière pourrait
suffire à contenir l'épidémie
moi je pense que pour contenir
l'épidémie il faut chercher beaucoup
plus systématiquement les gens qui sont
positifs et pas testé seulement les
symptomatique et leurs contacts n'ai
testé l'ensemble de la population
il y a que comme ça qu'on arrivera à
contrôler cette épidémie dans les pays
où on a testé très largement la
l'épidémie a été très bien contrôlé à
taïwan 24 millions d'habitants cette
mort est donc ils savent très bien géré
la chose et c'est la règle c'est tester
tester tester donc il faut tester
beaucoup plus largement la population et
on peut faire des tests groupe et on
peut rassembler les prélèvements de 20
personnes et rechercher des virus dans
un tube dans lequel on a mis les
prélèvements de 20 personnes si c'est
négatif les vingt personnes sont
négatives c'est quand même assez
efficace si on a des limites et je me
permets de vous couper parce que c'est
vrai que les citoyens que nous sommes on
est parfois un petit peu perdu avec ces
tests on a tous autour de nous des gens
qui ont fait des tests et qui sont
curieusement négatif alors qu'ils
avaient tous les symptômes est ce que
ces tests sont véritablement fille à
l'eau aujourd'hui aucun pince n'est
parfait mais si vous enlevez déjà sept
positifs qui contamine autour de lui sur
10 vous avez déjà beaucoup gagné
donc le fait que ça soit pas parfait
n'est pas une raison pour ne pas le
faire aucun test diagnostic n'a
absolument parfait il ya toujours des
faux négatifs et quelquefois aussi des
faux positifs donc c'est pas du tout une
raison pour ne pas tester aujourd'hui
quand vous entendez le professeur raoul
tu as un marseillais qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui qui dit que selon lui
l'épidémie va s'évanouir alors il ne dit
pas que la circulation du virus va
s'arrêter mais que l'épidémie va sivan
nuit sous va s'évanouir que les cours au
bord est plutôt basse vous le trouvez
irresponsable de parler ainsi
il a aussi dit que ça allait être une
petite gripette c'est pas vraiment une
petite grille patiente actu est quand
même des quantités de gens à la place
sur la planète entière donc il n'a pas
fait preuve il était pas très éclairé ce
jour-là donc maintenant il nous montre
les courbes qui sont les faits du confit
de manque
diminués mais maintenant les contacts
entre les gens augmentent donc forcément
le risque var et augmenté et on peut pas
dire que les gens respectent les
règlements barrière admirablement tout
le monde devrait porter des masques
quand même d'or et tous les personnes
que vous avez interviewé n'avait pas de
masque couvert c'est vrai oui je sais
bien et le gouvernement un pathogène sur
le sujet des masques d'une façon
absolument colossal donc qu'est-ce que
je peux je peux vous dire les pays où on
la recommande l usage du masque ont
quand même beaucoup moins de problème
donc c'est évidemment ça qu'il fallait
faire maintenant il ya des masses qu'il
faudrait changer comme discours soient
claires mais le discours a toujours
aussi cafouilleux donc je pense qu'il
faut porter un masque
dès qu'on sort en de chez soi encore
plus si on rentre dans un endroit fermé
à magasins etc mais aussi dehors parce
que on peut rencontrer des gens qui
parlent qui crache et le virus peut
arriver sur votre figure donc porter des
masques
mercereau on restera sur ce conseil
catherine hill merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france